the AK deagle and op are the three most
iconic guns in CS go their popularity
practically transcends the game itself
Freiburg proves it only for a moment
how's that Trading
but those who actually play the game
know that there is another gun that is
just as deserving of such hype the USP
its design sound and feel make it one of
the most satisfying weapons in gaming
from the meaty thump of squeezing off
around to the gush you hear when it
connects to the head on the side of the
USB I've gave an enormous Point that's a
very nice shot from here man dispatch
again what are you doing that's four
kills from him monstrous there's the ace
as well however the USP isn't the only
choice for those on CT when CS go first
came out the only option was its sibling
the P2000 and it has always been a
deadly handgun in its own right does
land flashbang is in what the hell is
going on yes what are you doing but
players gravitated towards the USP after
it came out and eventually the P2000 all
but disappeared they set up right now
from phase it's gonna be tested what a
flick to land and rain oh my goodness
what is he doing that was absolutely
phenomenal but should you you at home
actually be using the USP is the P2000
secretly better are we all just blindly
following the pros and missing out on a
handgun that could actually be
beneficial to the less gifted does the
usp's accuracy truly outweigh the p2000s
ammo capacity or is there actually a
psychological reason for what's going on
and ultimately should you make the
switch
[Applause]
okay as I mentioned the P2000 was
originally the only CT starting pistol
way back when the game first came out
and even when compared to the Glock it
was still an angle holding melon popper
Dupree and device have nowhere to go
completely surrounded Chucky finding one
Dupree now takes one takes two takes the
third to three just makes it look so
good however once the all-important arms
deal update rolled around the USPS was
reintroduced to the franchise and by the
first ever CS go major usage between the
two pistols was split that Trend
continued through 2014 and 2015. and as
a spectator watching the best of the
best do Unthinkable things with both
it was sort of hard to tell if there was
actually a difference Dennis is
extremely good on these pistols to start
that momentum on fast play very fast
play and there it is oh my God
oh my God you on point all three kills
again I'm done don't even buy guns just
this guy could use a USB for the entire
game and I would be convinced because G2
certainly has to be convinced it might
be there
[Applause]
an absolutely perfect round there are
still four liquid players towards me now
they know but it's too late Dennis with
a fast crack on a simple sure he could
get to return but the bomb will be
planted Dennis posting a defense by the
APC now as that bomb ticks away three
versus three as Dennis pops moreheads is
this guy done just yet I don't even know
he's got all of my super support as well
this is a very tough re-entry for liquid
Dennis is getting in there again and
there might be one more of course
with the ace but by 2016 the P2000 had
all but disappeared from Pro play sure
some stayed true to the p2k but not
enough to make a dent in the game's
statistics but why what exactly were the
differences well the two most obvious
differences can be noticed just by
equipping them the USP has a massive
suppressor and the p2k has more bullets
both in its magazine and Reserve pool
the benefit of having more bullets is
pretty straightforward but does the
suppressor actually do anything well
sort of compared to the P2000 the
suppressor on the USP does make it a lot
quieter especially at longer ranges
so hypothetically you could be a bit
sneakier with the USP since it is quiet
and has no tracers you could beam
enemies from behind without them even
noticing but that's probably only going
to matter in lobbies where no one is
really communicating and if that's the
case
you probably have bigger problems than
which CT pistol is better on top of that
the silencer does have its drawbacks as
fun as it is to let the old dog bark
once in a while taking the silencer off
the USP quickly makes it the worst gun
in the game but more importantly the
input for taking off your silencer is
bound to your right click and you can't
change it without screwing up your other
binds like scoping in on the op this
means that people like me and actual
professionals can sometimes die in a
gunfight because they inadvertently got
stuck in an animation is that one piece
of YouTube but in the two and four I
don't want to write them up
is right click anyway if we do a deeper
dive and look into the gun's actual
stats they're the same in many aspects
the damage armor penetration rate of
fire and range modifier are all
identical the only difference is The
Recoil control the USP edges the P2000
out ever so slightly and as a result it
technically improves the accuracy
whether you're standing crouching or
moving I say technically because the
difference isn't that drastic back in
2014 three clicks Philip did a video
where he showcased it wonderfully
standing still you can see that all of
the bullets land much closer to the
Cross F or my classified USPS the spread
horizontally seems the same crouching
makes the USP even more precise
I was surprised about the running
accuracy the P2000 felt more accurate I
swear that some of the bullets from the
USP hit the walls though I can't see
them here once again it appears that the
USP is more accurate in this regard and
finally crouching the P2000 loses
against the usp's far neater damage
pattern now as good as that video is
it's a bit too big brain for me three
clicks were shown
come when spamming your pistol what if
you're just tapping away at range as you
would in a typical fire fight well then
the difference in accuracy becomes even
less noticeable don't get me wrong the
USP is still more accurate but with the
differences being so minor you'd think a
large chunk of the player base would
still be using the p2k for the ammo
alone but the thing is CS go apart from
all its other intricacies is ultimately
a game about shooting people in the face
and at the pro level players have gotten
really really good at that you won't see
nearly as many players spamming their
USP in a pistol round hoping for the
best they tend to hit their shots poison
therefore the context on a
makes it so quick that being said the
vast majority of people who actually
play Counter-Strike are not Pros I am a
reasonably high level player myself and
I with USB shots all the time so why is
it that we all just equip it without
question well there are a ton of things
that we CS go players simply take for
granted maybe we like the sound maybe a
friend told us to use the USP when we
were first starting or perhaps we saw a
pro use it and never gave it a second
thought and the USP is the perfect
example of that herd mentality since it
has resulted in a gun practically
disappearing from the game which I think
is a shame because ultimately there is a
massive case for the p2k for the
umpteenth time it has more bullets and
as small as that may sound it is
extremely important in a game like CS go
we are talking about a game of inches
sometimes just one more bullet in a
magazine can make all the difference p2k
in hand it's gonna spot a Tau immediate
First Blood being drawn
by Hellraisers and still gonna stick
around towards mid this is this is risky
here that walks is going to continue to
aggressive find another one finds the
third finds the four then he gets the
A's walk sick on top of that you can
really feel the usp's lack of Reserve
bullets in certain tense situations
missed some shots spam some smoke and
before you know it you can be scouring
the ground for a Glock in the middle of
a retake and as good as Pros are at
tapping heads even they can run out of
ammo but look at this he actually sees
two people flusher flying shot takes
down Apex and now they're in the beef
bomb side flasher getting a chance to
reload backup is already here marquisima
with a stunning shot to shot down all of
Meister it's now a 4v4 JW still alive
and he gets a kill on prims Russia in
the back lines he's out of ammo a knife
is out what's happening
all that being said I feel as if there's
just something more here something that
we're just not seeing a deeper layer
that we've yet to uncover and now the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about listen you all know by now that
I'm not the tax shooter guy and I
normally just pop in for the number
stuff but that's not all I'm good at so
allow me to be an armchair psychologist
for a minute even though I'm not
actually in an armchair you know what I
mean a few years ago people make games
released a video discussing the Thompson
machine gun from Wolfenstein enemy
territory I know that's a pretty hard
left turn from CS go but I promise this
all makes sense during the multiplayer
beta testers complained that the
Thompson was too overpowered in
comparison to the axis MP40 but it turns
out that couldn't have been possible
they're identical they're absolutely the
same damage
rate of fire reload speed clip size
absolutely the same the players are
wrong this is this is bad feedback and
then we look at the server data and
players are getting more kills with the
Thompson than the MP40 the players are
right and after ragging their brains for
a while the developers discovered the
true copper the sound the Thompson had a
meteor base in comparison to the thin
tinny sound of the MP40 and the devs
were actually forced to Nerf that sound
for the sake of balance and I think
that's similar to what could be going on
with the USP and the p2k in our previous
cracked episode on weapon skins we
talked about how they can have a
psychological effect on how you perform
with a gun and that same idea can be
applied to how a gun sounds and this
isn't even just some ethereal Feel
Better Play better stuff there's been
actual science done on things like this
in a meta-analysis that's a study of a
bunch of other studies All of These Fine
upstanding scientists found a pretty
substantial link between improved
reaction time as well as higher
performance scores and tasks like
communication driving navigation and
Target acquisition when comparing test
is done with Visual and auditory
feedback to those with only visual
feedback now they may not actually be
doing this test on people playing
Counter-Strike but that just means we
can do that one someday ultimately I
feel like it's safe to say that these
tests certainly show that there's at
least some positive effect from auditory
feedback and Counter-Strike it's been
well documented that I barely play on
ECS go but even I have to agree that the
USP does sound pretty thick
meanwhile the P2000 well I think it's
safe to say that it leaves a lot to be
desired
what
the
it's also interesting to know that in
2016 the same year that the P2000
dropped off the face of the Earth the
pistol sounds were updated to what we
know today though maybe I'm reading a
little too much into it the point is if
something feels or in this case sounds
better to use people are more likely to
gravitate towards it and find success
with it all stats being equal and that
was the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about but all this
philosophizing about sound design and
anecdotes about Ammo don't tell the full
story and so far we've only tested the
guns by firing at a blank wall so we
decided to load up a pre-fire practice
course on Mirage to see how each weapon
would fare if you went to the same path
every time now I personally pride myself
on my ability with pistols so I
recruited Devin cool the writer on this
project who admits that he struggles
with pistols
uh despite all other aspects of his game
being Flawless and after about an hour
of him running through the course his
average time was almost identical for
both pistols it still doesn't tell the
full story of course but it does give us
a little bit more insight at the very
least it's safe to say that these two
guns are extremely similar to one
another except of course for the fact
that we wouldn't have been able to even
complete the course with the USP if we
didn't have unlimited ammo turned on and
I don't think we're the only ones who've
caught on to the potential benefits of
the p2k despite the usp's seven plus
year reign some players have
experimented with its forgotten brother
and even more recently we've started to
see some of the best players in the
world give it a try but now he's a part
of the pack
and we'll see if that can help things
for now it's a liege with the p2k pop it
a couple heads down ramp goes back in
for more three four from a leash looking
for the pistol round Ace but you Kinder
oh he won't get that chance to steal it
nice he's running left here he comes the
Karate Kid chops him down and already I
see two pairs of door barrettes that's
quady simple gonna open up down through
mid it's a Swift one top onto magisk no
attempt to trade that one you've gotta
run at him you've got to run him down
here and he's just going through the
motions backing up playing oh what no oh
Dupree despite that the USP still holds
favor within the community and the same
can be said at the pro level
USPS I tried P2000 it's better I'm going
to say USPS right now because uh it's
just statistically better than the p2k
having the bullets isn't worth it listen
there are plenty of useless weapons in
CS go but in that same arms deal update
valve also added the m4a1s which
continues to have a historic rivalry
with its counterpart the A4 and a1s
serve different purposes and rewards
separate play Styles which is a
deliberate Choice made by the developers
the same cannot be said for the p2k and
the USP but I do not think that the
fault lies with valve on this one as we
have seen the p2k is not just a
serviceable sidearm but potentially an
even better choice for players who
either really like to shoot a lot of
bullets or aren't as confident in their
head shotting abilities listen it is
perfectly understandable to follow in
the footsteps of professionals and other
players you trust but part of getting
good at any competitive game is
experimenting Haitian and practice the
USP is not in fact a one-size-fits-all
solution for every player so why not
give the p2k a try don't worry
I told you
calm down keep going I might as well get
some awesome man I'm hiding
that's easy twitter.com
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock
[Music]